so the one thing my mom looks forward to
every single day
is her daily walks alone around the
neighborhood and i literally called her
the other day to tell her
that she cannot do that anymore since
the beginning of cover 19
agents have experienced a 1900 increase
in asian
hate crimes and that number is just the
ones that have been documented and
written down so it doesn't even include
the ones that weren't written down and
weren't reported
or the ones that were misrecorded as
non-anti-asian
hate incidences so growing up in a
predominantly white neighborhood
with very few asians in my city i've
been called
ching [ __ ] chung li go back to china and
guess what i did
nothing absolutely nothing my mother
and her asian american friends have been
spat on
coughed at and also experienced many
anti-asian slurs and we might not think
that calling covid19 the quote
chinese virus or the kung flu or the wu
flu
are bad or even connected to this
violence but it absolutely
is because that emboldens that racism it
emboldens those anti-asian
hate sentiments we're just taught to
stay quiet and turn the other cheek
just mind your own business we have all
been trapped in this model minority
stereotype
you guys all have heard oh asians are
smart they're good at math
they're educated they go to college they
painted us as the model
immigrant that everyone should actually
be like
and this created a wedge between asian
americans and other people of color
since we were
painted as privileged listen it's not
getting any better
asian americans are being attacked
specifically
our elders it's our duty as americans
to speak up about what is happening
right now
and what needs to be heard when we say
racism against asians is normalized it
kind of brings you to ask the question
compared to who we're comparing it to
black people's experiences which have
been made hyper-visible
and end up in us playing the oppression
olympics the same way saying asian lives
matter might seem harmless at first but
it's actually co-opting the black lives
matter movement
a movement working to combat police
brutality against black people it
doesn't make sense to try to move the
attention from a movement that isn't
relevant and try to use it for our own
benefit
please realize that being anti-black
when spreading awareness about the
anti-asian violence happening recently
is not only unproductive but also
harmful
asian liberation is so inextricably
linked to black liberation and we should
be working to uplift each other it's
important to stand up for our community
and to prevent this from continuing but
being anti-black or anti-blm calling for
increased police surveillance is not the
answer the police aren't going to fix
this like an asian 19 year old was shot
and killed by police on december 30th
while he was having a mental health
crisis and had his hands up police
brutality is an issue that affects the
asian community as well
the violence against asians occurring is
a symptom of white supremacy and should
be another reason for solidarity i want
to make it clear that awareness should
not be the end goal of your activism
it's a way to rally people to support
your cause and incite action
but it's not going to solve the issue
protests for example are a tool used to
put pressure on a government or other
higher-ups to respond to the demands of
a movement there needs to be actual
demands and measures to address the
problems of a system
do you want to pass a law do you want
reforms as an example we can see how blm
has been working since 2013
some other demands being to defund the
police or to end qualified immunity to
fire and charge the police that have
murdered members of the black community
this isn't to compare blm to advocating
against anti-asian hate crimes
but we can't just blindly support any
and all activism against racism towards
asians because we're angry
without tangible goals we won't see real
change because reactionary activism will
only result in short-lived anger and
burnout i agree we need unity and to
push for change but i think we should do
it in a way that's productive if you'd
like to help out or support the aapi
asian american pacific islanders
community the first thing and most
impactful thing that you can do is stop
calling
covet 19 the chinese virus the wu flu or
the kung flu
call it cobit 19 or coronavirus you
should
also be calling out your friends when
they say that if you have friends that
are saying chinese virus tell them not
to say it explain why the next thing is
that you should be following asian
american creators and educators on your
social media
platforms my favorites are amanda wynn
teach and transform and michelle kim kim
among others
you can also follow me at pink matre i
also post about these kinds of things
lastly support asian american
organizations such as the smithsonian
apa
asian pacific americans association look
speaking up is incredibly
uncomfortable but i am going to
encourage you no matter how big
or small your platform is you have a
voice especially if you're asian
especially if you're asian american we
all have our own story and we cannot be
silent
let's break the model minority
stereotype and let's stop asian hate
you